and that's fun
right but that's not the big takeaway
the big takeaway is what are they doing
like think of that think about what
they're doing
what can filmmakers learn from the pixar
theory i think what filmmakers can learn
from the pixar theory is is that
just how fans think
and and for people that don't know the
pixar theory the pixel theory is the
unofficial
fan theory that all the pixar movies
exist in one narrative universe and
they're all connected in crazy ways uh
where pixar the official line from pixar
is that all these things are
disconnected right and they don't have
anything to do with each other uh but
fans they've constructed their own crazy
interconnected universe and so
uh what what filmmakers can learn from
that is that innately
fans love connection they love things to
cross over they love the the one story
that they love to connect with the other
story that they love they desire this
and if if they don't see a connection
they will figure out how there is a
connection and if you look at fan
theaters not just the picture theory but
just like any fan theories there are are
fun and interesting but it shows that
the the psychology and the mentality
of the modern fandom that they crave
connection you look at something like um
you know with uh the fact that uh if you
watch episode one of star wars um in the
galactic senate scene there's a there's
a pod of aliens that are all ets
which means wait a minute that's e-t is
is in the star wars universe uh which
and so now these things are connected in
a really interesting way which then if
you then go watch et that makes that
that uh that um explains why e.t reacts
to the kid in the yoda mask not because
he's an alien but the reason he reacts
to the yoda mask is because he's he
knows yoda
because he's from the star wars universe
which means if when e.t makes the
bicycle fly at the end of the movie he's
not using weird alien magic he's using
the force which means et's a jedi which
is awesome and fans will work all that
stuff out
and and which is ridiculous but it's fun
but it's ridiculous but what it shows so
we shouldn't discard that as filmmakers
say oh that's just a crazy fan theory no
no like look at
why the fan is doing that and and figure
out like what's the mentality and what's
the psychology behind that they crave
connection you think about this think
about imminent shyamalan what you know
people haven't been excited about in
night shyamalan in 15 years right
but then when he made when he made split
right which was a solid movie and it was
good but the best part of split was at
the end when they were revealed the
connection to unbreakable
and that's when people said oh my god
i'm not shyamalan he's back he imagined
was great
his his filmmaking didn't necessarily
improve
he started connecting
his stories and the fans got excited
about it so then you had unbreakable
then he connected it with split and then
they converged those things into into
glass
and and he created his own little
connected universe out of those three
films which fans loved and it really
revived his career that one decision to
connect those films revived his whole
career in a great way right kevin smith
you look back kevin smith who broke in
with with the glut of independent
filmmakers that broke into the 90s the
thing that separated him from all those
other filmmakers is the fact that he
started connecting interconnecting all
his movies his clerks connected the mall
rats was collected connected chasing amy
which connected to jay and silent bob
and and uh you know they all existed in
in you know this this little town in
jersey and they they they you know they
referred to the different
the the plot points of the different
movies in a really interesting way uh
but still in the way that they could
still stand alone but there was obvious
there was a connection
that separated him from all those other
filmmakers and and and was able to uh he
created a community
around his ip that other filmmakers
weren't able to do because they didn't
connect not and listen i think we could
probably i think kevin smith would agree
that he's not necessarily the best
filmmaker of all those filmmakers that
broke broke in in the 90s right
but he was able to build just such a
rabidly
devout community because the fans were
excited about the connections between
the stories and so so for me the pixar
theory is all
about the fans and the way they think
it's not about i mean it's interesting
to think about of like well the witch
you know the witch and brave is actually
the little girl in monsters inc and
because when you when you see the
witch's cabin there's a there's a
there's an etching of mike wazowski and
sully in the wood carving of the of the
wall which which uh which then i think
the theory says uh uh after
after celly leaves boo at the end of
monsters inc
she spends the rest of her life
searching for him and uses the magic of
the doors to ultimately like get trapped
in uh you know ancient scotland and but
she she understands how to use the magic
of the doors to then turn people into
bears and the reason she turns them into
bears is she's trying to recreate sully
in her own life will always without you
know with tragic results and it's like
however the story goes right or the fact
that i think that the pixar series
theory says that
you know um uh if you watch the end of
frozen uh uh rapunzel and the dude that
rapunzel uh uh flynn that do the
rapunzel mary's they're at elsa's
coronation which means they're connected
which uh then the the the theory said
that elsa's parents died in a in a ship
sinking accident and um but they
actually didn't die the ship sank they
actually made it to a deserted island
restarted their lives had a son on the
island who was tarzan and then the ship
that sank was the ship that the little
mermaid explores at the beginning of the
little mermaid when she finds the fork
and all that stuff and they create all
this connection
and that's fun
right but that's not the big takeaway
the big takeaway is what are they doing
like think of that think about what
they're doing they're they're working
hard
to create connection
that's what they want they love it that
excites them right connection excite
that this is why it's why people this is
the brilliance of the mcu this is the
burnings of what what what of what's
going on with the mandalorian this is
this is this is this is
what this is even in video games with
with things like kingdom hearts and and
and when
when you throw you know uh uh uh you
know a crossover character into a mortal
kombat game we love crossover and
connection you look at chicago fire
chicago med chicago pd all the biggest
like raiding ratings events in tv are
those crossover events right as a kid i
loved it when scooby-doo crossed over
with batman and robin and the the
globetrotters and there was the
connection like we the fans always loved
that stuff and it's always played out
which
makes me wonder
why would
a filmmaker
ever make things without connections to
other things
if you do you're going against the
psychology of the audience because the
pixar theory
for first and foremost shows the mindset
of the modern fan
which means when you create something
and you're not connecting anything
you're you're
you're going against the expectation the
audience and and you know ultimately you
know that's uh uh i think if you if you
create things understanding your
audience and understand how they think
and what motivates them and what they
like uh if if you read up on this
philosophy called phenomenology uh
phenomenology the philosophy of of the
the highest the the the most art the
greatest artistic achievement of the
artist is not the art itself it's the
experience that you create
between the audience and the art the
experience is the is the achievement
not the art
but the only way to get the experience
is to understand
what the audience wants and how to
create that experience with the art and
it's the combination that creates the
experience so so you have to understand
the psychology of the audience
if you want to create that magical
experience
and and the pixar theory gives us a very
clear window
into
how the audience thinks
so is that why people love crime
podcasts or puzzles because we're
connecting we're trying to connect of
course i think it's just how we that's
how we operate this that's how we work
the how our brains work right and and so
we're always trying to connect pieces
and and and our brain
our brain does it for us sometimes
subconsciously just how we are we like
we like these interesting connections
and it plays out in entertainment uh
whether it's superhero stuff whether
it's what the walking dead has been
doing with crossing over all their shows
whether what you know what hannah
barbara did way back in the day whatever
nbc does like crossover events has been
a staple of modern entertainment for
decades so this isn't a new thing it's
always worked right it's working even
more now in a sort of a modern
multi-platform transmedia market uh but
but this isn't sort of a new development
it's always worked right so i think
understanding as a filmmaker
understanding the psychology of the
audience and creating content that
connects with other content
it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna again
just increase your chances for your
entertainment to really
to really succeed in today's market
you